um okay let's go next to Alan from Miami
Florida Alan welcome
Alan you were on the air but it looks
like you have the wrong microphone
selected welcome to the program you can
speak if you can get configured
correctly
and last chance for Alan from Miami
Florida who is in tech hell as we might
call it welcome Allen hello can you hear
me now I can hear you
how are you David I'm doing well
good good
um so I had a question about EVS I find
EV very interesting I know you've talked
about them
um in the past on several occasions so
um now as you probably know the biggest
issue with EVS
um from a from a cost standpoint is the
the most expensive part right which is
the battery and more specifically the
materials you sourced and used to
manufacture these batteries yes right
and if you look at the trajectory of EV
prices or EV vehicles
um their prices they have been going
down
but
um the price of these
of these batteries are still a big
impediment right yes so what do you
think maybe the government can do what
kind of role do you think or a positive
role
um do you think the government can play
um in trying to resolve this issue or
helping to resolve this issue the reason
I ask is because you know a lot of
people in the EV space will say that the
the biggest impediment for the middle
class or let's say just regular folk
being able to afford an EV
um is this issue basically is is the
cost of the materials to manufacture the
batteries so there's a couple different
things here first of all in terms of
what the government can do that's not
the most interesting question to me
because like the government can do what
it's done in other industries that it
wants to support rebates subsidies
preferential tax treatment the
government has its tools that it can use
and I'm fine with the government doing
that I think the problem you're pointing
out is going to resolve itself with more
electric vehicle demand and as as
adoption increases I mean listen it's
like when you look at
um uh computer processors right and you
look at I remember when we got from
Radio Shack this 100 megahertz Pentium
computer and it was like twenty five
hundred dollars in whatever year that
was which is like a lot more money now
you know it's probably five or six grand
now and now you get you know
multi-gigahertz processors for way less
buy some of the same
um laws that govern the reduced price of
hard drive storage and the reduced cost
of processing power I think you're going
to see absolutely the same thing with
with electric vehicle batteries the
other thing is
communicating to people that because
electric vehicles are so much more
efficient than internal combustion
engines on a per mile basis it's also
possible that while The Upfront cost of
an electric vehicle can be higher
although although those costs are also
coming down the long-term cost because
the electricity is cheaper than the gas
and the efficiency is higher so your
cost per mile is lower the total cost of
ownership is is going to be less so I
think it's a matter of we've got to
communicate that that's already the case
the prices will continue to come down
battery recycling and reuse is going to
be developed all of these things are
these are really engineering problems
that are that are like what we saw in
Computing and in other spaces it's all
going to get resolved is my view
okay I see well it seems to me that that
as far as you mentioned uh recycling
that's a huge thing that many companies
are trying to to push is to try to get
um these batteries to kind of get back
into the the life cycle because you
still have valuable uh use but it seems
and it could be wrong here maybe you can
correct me on this but it seems like I
don't know if the government or federal
government has any sort of program to
recycle or a sense of ice recycling of
these things because that I don't know
but they may they may or they may not
yeah so that that could be an area maybe
that that sort of The Government Can can
uh can address because so far right now
it seems like it's just startups that
are coming out of nowhere that are
trying to resolve that issue and the
government isn't doing much I would like
the government to more uh incentivizing
this uh technology development but it's
happening Alan it's all happening
appreciate it Alan from Miami Florida
quite a scene down there that I can tell
you for sure let's go oh just a reminder
for everybody waiting in Discord to chat
with me if your nickname is anything
other than a name and a location uh
whether it's nicknames or single words
or whatever the case may be uh jokes
you're not going to get called on which
is fine if you're just listening but
just so you know why you won't be
getting called on let's go next to
moshev from Toronto Canada welcome
hello David hello
hello
um so I was wondering I don't know how
how invested you are in uh Canadian
politics but I was wondering if I could
get your opinion on how well you think
uh Justin Trudeau has been doing over
the last while and and your opinion
about the uh the uh the new uh
conservative party lever can serve party
leader Pierre palia who just won the
um who just won the race for a
conservative party leader you know I
think it wouldn't be appropriate for me
to comment not because I think it's
inappropriate to comment on foreign
leaders but because there are just so
many people who follow it much more
closely than I do that I couldn't
possibly give you a very informed take I
will say I recently when I was in
Montreal uh met with and chatted with um
MP Anthony House Father who likes what
Trudeau is doing but they're in the same
party right so he may have a dog in that
fight so to speak
um but no I don't I don't I don't think
I'm informed enough to really be saying
Hey listen to my opinion about Canadian
politics
yeah well they they the MPS will always
vote for the people in their party no
matter what pretty much that's pretty
much how it works well tell me I mean
how do you think things are day to day
in Toronto
well yeah I mean yeah we're dealing with
uh the cost of living being in a in a
pretty terrible place right now
um
um the government's working on getting
Dental clear in place which which is
interesting the question I guess the
question I don't I wonder what you would
think is is uh if now is the right time
to start implementing like these these
uh high-cost uh programs
um at this point where everyone is
trying to like save money produce
inflation you know you set a Dental Care
Program yeah yeah they want to start
they want to start doing a federal
program we get coverage from the
government for uh for dental care
because up until now it's it's complete
that's completely been uh private and
only only paid for by private insurance
well listen again without commenting
specifically about what's going on in
Canada there are always people who will
say this is the wrong time to do
anything that involves spending money
but my view tends to be when it comes to
things like Health Care why would you
wait people the the sooner people get
care the better off we are
uh-huh even if that means risking
um the um like the money being like that
money being spent elsewhere well you'd
have to then say well what else do you
want to spend it on and compare
oh I would say not spend not spend it at
all
uh as a uh as of this current moment
yeah okay all right well I'd like to see
the numbers on it but again I'm not the
best position to comment on that
okay all right thank you for your time
all right thanks motion from Toronto
great to hear from you